es gibt sondern richtig kreativen neuen
youtube trend experten sagen ist ein
krasser als der gern am style ich glaube
jeder von euch weiß wovon ich rede
es haben schon die bekanntesten youtuber
deutschlands europas und der welt klima
hat es in ganz vielen bällen gemacht wie
du schauen
und zahlen des jungen schreien es ist an
der zeit das ganze auf ein neues level
zu eheleute wollen wen das wollte den
komischen substanzen baden nicht dabei
weh tue das wasser probiert und einfach
nur komische sachen damit macht und
deswegen review next level meine damen
und herren ich war heute nichts
geringerem als wasser ich fahre heute in
wasser zunächst einmal müssen wir das
ganze hier irgendwie rein machen
oh mein gott wieso ist es immer noch so
heidi wanne fühlt sich meine damen und
herren also ich glaube der abschlusses
zu
das wasser nimmt auf jeden fall zu
ich reise immer voller alter
mailand würden so umfasst erwähnt so
sieht dass hier für mich gerade aus also
ich warte einfach wird diese wanne da
vorne mit wasser befüllt ist aber ich
laufe das dauert noch ein bisschen
deswegen spricht erstmals 2000 jahre vor
2000 jahre später
wir sind auf einem guten weg in der zeit
wo es gerade das wasser da hinten in die
badewanne rief freunde ich frag mich
einfach woher kommen die fairtrade dass
man irgendetwas bade ich meine wenn ich
jetzt wirklich so wie jeder youtuber
diesen trend auch mitmachen würde würde
ich mir irgendetwas komisches suchen wie
beispielsweise tiefkühlpizzen die eine
badewanne schmeißt und da drin war
ich meine da kommen leute nicht auf die
bescheuerten ideen nicht meinem erwartet
denn beispielsweise in nutella oder
wackelpudding vor allem wieso hat es
noch niemand in wasser getan
das ist doch dass kranke der welt ich
stelle den bass arien aus ist alles was
ihr denkt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich das
ist normales wasser indem ich in berlin
dort aber es ist sehr heißes wasser es
ist kein normales wasser sondern wasser
aus der leitung
was mache ich mit meinem leben war
kommen wir hier zu dem moment auf den
alle gewartet haben ich traurig noch
nicht direkt in die wanne zu steigen
weil das noch nie jemand gemacht hat im
wasser zu warnen
das ist die wirklich sehr gefährlich
also mache das nicht da ich stecke jetzt
einfach mal fußball ein
ich tue das dorf für euch freunde die
steht wird eine buße der wanne
freundlich zwecke den zweiten mit europa
und ich mich verrückt dass sie gerade
ich denke jetzt beide hände in die wanne
ich muss halt ganz stark sein ich setze
mich jetzt hin ich vollkommen dort hat
man t shirt noch an
ja gut luca erwarte leute machen das
natürlich irgendwie vorbereitet und klug
und nicht toll alter ja ich sitze jetzt
in der man was machen denn youtube also
wenn sie diese videos machen was mache
ich hier mit meinem leben was machen
youtube-nutzer wenn es im sommer warnte
davor dass gerade das ganze wasser über
gespannt so eine tolle youtube 30 hat in
seinem video auch die substanz des
materials getestet indem er gewartet hat
also werde ich das jetzt auch mit dem
wasser tun ich traue mich jetzt wirklich
eine hand voll wasser zunehmend davon
die substanz ist macht das wird sie
nicht zu hause nach freunde was tue ich
eigentlich dieser youtube trend ist der
beste werde ich lege mich hin das
masters ist so fucking heißt und ich
verbrenne hier fasst immerhin gut das
ist richtig schnell hoch zu hoch also
ohne spaß geben damit nimmt die bahn
versucht hochzukommen also heißt es geht
klar aber es ist schon schwierig ich
habe geputzt hat man in welche planungen
sehen dafür aber ich habe voll das
wasser die schwarze gespritzt das was
ihr von dem video meinte damen irgendwer
ist gerade nach hause gekommen das war
es hier mit dem video ich habe mir
gedacht das ist
dass jeder irgendwie irgendwas badet und
ich finde es total bescheuert deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht nicht gerade
einfach im wasser um euch selber zu
zeigen wie dumm das ist dass die leute
dabei zugucken wie sie in irgendwelchen
nahrungsmittel und wird weiß ich auch
immer warten die sie danach wegschmeißen
nicht ein bisschen bescheuert also wenn
ich meinen auch musicals reagieren und
so sehr irgendwie noch winzig weil wir
das ganze community macht aber eben das
sind denkbar
ich verstehe es einfach nicht ich wollte
das ganze natürlich wie du kannst deine
probleme hat deswegen gegen den wasser
gebracht vielleicht findet ihr es witzig
das wasser ständig jetzt übrigens auch
wenn es euch gefallen hat und ich
eventuell auch mal ein wasser duschen
soll
okay das ist vielleicht auch ein
bisschen zu hart das auf jeden fall mal
leicht darum findet ihr in zwei die
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnte man
den kanal abonnieren und hier findet ihr
gegen ein altes video eingeblendet also
pech dass auf jeden fall machen
kommentiert mal wasser wenn ihr euch
noch dran sagt war und und